if you had to have a threesome with one  male actor who would it be i don't know  why bob de niro  popped in my head it was like him or  pesci dude that would be so cool does  the [ __ ]  just those three  oh yeah yeah yeah there's two more wait  we're [ __ ] each other  i'd [ __ ] peschy  why not  dude it's a conversation starter at like  a dinner party it's like well you know i  [ __ ] joe peggy  what  you what's funny i'll say this i this  girl i used to whose apartment i rented  when i first moved to new york uh she's  kind of a socialite she's friends with  all of us in the comedy world uh she's  only [ __ ] three people in her life one  of them is robert de niro  i swear to god i swear to god